[Music]
[Applause]
Jason mccourtney joins us what was your
reaction when you heard Usher was going
to be the halftime show Super Bowl I'm
I'm excited I'm an usher fan so uh
Usher's on my playlist so I I'm looking
forward to hopefully I can be in the
building and we're going to the game
did you ever sneak out to see the
halftime performance when you played for
the Patriots in the Super Bowl
I didn't I only got a chance of playing
one of them now I had been to that was
my fifth one I was in attendance uh
because obviously my brother played so I
was so focused on the game I didn't have
time to uh to go ahead and sneak out for
the halftime performance who was the
halftime performance
I don't know
Paulie do you have it I think it was a
Maroon 5 Travis Scott
oh I think
yeah but I I literally have no idea
Belichick would never let you guys do
that right oh he would have told you to
just stay out there
and enjoy the game from there I don't
know what's the worst loss you ever
suffered because we're like the number
here's Denver losing by 50.
and and how do you react when you're in
the locker room when you lose when
you're totally embarrassed
do you remember that game the New
England Patriots playing the Tennessee
Titans the Titans had on the old
throwback Oilers game it was in the snow
in Foxboro I think that one was 59 is
zero that was the worst loss I had that
was my rookie year that clip continues
to be played but
um it's tough like it's complete silence
usually when you go in the locker room
everybody's just looking at each other I
mean you and we lost I feel like 50s is
that kind of exception of the game when
someone puts out that 70 I said today on
our show it was like a high school
basketball score 70-21 team is way
better than the other one that's
embarrassing that's tough in the locker
room after yeah but your margin of
defeat is worse than what the Broncos
suffered there
no doubt about it but it comes to a
certain point where it's almost like a
mercy rule where the offense no longer
is trying to throw the ball they're just
handing it off so for them to actually
get 70. the Dolphins had their backups
in the game and they were still making
big plays late in the game so that that
was ugly to witness
what do you see that the Dolphins are
doing that's differently than anybody
else right now
I would say to play design all the
shifts emotions the way Mike McDaniel
puts Tyreek Hill in motion so you can't
have a guy standing at the line of
scrimmage being able to jam them up and
then have somebody over the top that's
been the big difference and then two is
just healthy this year we looked at it
his numbers through three weeks last
year and his numbers through three three
weeks this year are exactly the same
completions yards the whole night it's
kind of incredible of what he's been
able to do so I would say play design
has been amazing it's a track team they
bring Devon a chain in with moster and
tyreal Jalen waddle didn't even play in
the game yesterday and they still scored
70 points what is it like when there's
fast like Fast guys know fast guys
Tyreek Hill is fast among fast guys
you can't simulate that in practice
right
that's a great way to say I remember the
first time I went against them and not
only is these fast he's quick but then
he has an amazing acceleration so he
starts fast he's not a guy that needs to
build and to your point it is just
different and when he comes out on the
field and everybody in the secondary is
yelling tens on the left tens on the
right he has that type of capability
where you always have to know where he's
aligned and where he can hurt you from
the first drive of the game he scores a
54-yard touchdown that you're right all
right we're in for a treat today and
that's what it was track team I know we
love to talk about the Cowboys win or
lose and now we have a different reason
it felt like they were reading their
press clippings like yeah we're great
defense great Michael Parsons maybe MVP
everything's going great Mike McCarthy
and then you have the Cardinals how do
you explain I know we got to give credit
to the Cardinals the Dallas had some
Dallas had some offensive lineman not in
there but you lose 28-16 how do you
explain that
uh for them you just were hoping you
could just continue to play New York New
Jersey teams for the entire season
because the first two weeks Giants and
jets was 70 to 10 and it didn't look
like they were going to be beat and they
just didn't look ready to play in the
sense they got in the Red Zone a bunch
of times couldn't convert and
defensively I know they lost Siobhan
Diggs this week but at the same time it
wasn't the past game that absolutely
killed them it was Arizona being able to
run the ball so sometimes maybe you need
that humbling loss early in the season
but then you gotta ask yourself at this
point with the Cowboys are they really
good or did they go against the Giants
and Jets team who are kind of down in
the dumps one without Aaron Rodgers and
the Giants and just struggled a little
bit early on this season so then you
really just start to wonder where this
team is
but also let's stay with the Jets here
for a moment I take away Aaron Rodgers
okay but I still have the nucleus there
that people thought was going to be
certainly a playoff Contender if not a
Super Bowl contender
unreal watching them Sunday offensively
just all right you maybe can't find so
they checked the ball down and it seemed
like they threw the ball away on every
single play I mean the fan was in the
stands losing his teeth as he's yelling
at Zach Wilson you it's hard to explain
why it was that bad offensively and I
know the Patriots have a really good
defense but even to the point where our
Gary Wilson if they go one-on-one at any
point in the game the hell with the play
Just chucked the ball up to him and see
what he can do with it they saw a briefs
Hall Dalvin cook so it's hard to
understand why it was still that bad
because the Jets defense I mean they
only gave up 15 points you got to be
able to do something and I think that's
the scary thing with Zach Wilson's
second overall pick and you were hoping
all right he's been around greatness one
of the best quarterbacks ever played his
game for the last five six months
something had to rub off and we're still
searching to see what could have
possibly rubbed off on him let's take
away the Cardinals and the Cowboys
result
um worse loss with the Colts beating the
Ravens in Baltimore uh the Texans
beating the Jags in Jacksonville
I'm gonna go to Texans and Jackson
beating Jacksonville Jacksonville in
that division AFC South you came in this
year like all right Trevor Lawrence last
year they stormed back they won that
first playoff game they go on a roll to
Kansas City they lose by seven just all
right if he takes another step we could
be talking about him in an MVP type of
season and then what they can do on that
division because you know rookie
quarterbacks with the Colts and with the
Texans kind of hitting reset and then
the Titans drafting levels but 10 other
struggle and they just haven't looked
all the way apart this year one and two
so far I know they lost it to Chiefs who
didn't play a good ball so I would say
that was the game I thought for them a
division opponent setting the tone early
on and they weren't able to do it all
right I'll leave you with this who has
more wins at the end of the season the
Denver Broncos
or the Colorado Buffaloes
oh I'm on Colorado Buffalo you give up
seven you give up 70 points I'm not
picking you for anything
okay
yeah but you got the Bears against
Denver coming up next week
somebody's got to win that game yeah
that's going to be a thriller that's
when we're all circling that we can't
wait uh to be a part of yeah somebody
does have to win that game
um when they don't have to they can talk
about it they could end in a time but
anybody in sports media would just
absolutely love them between those two
teams yeah to be able to talk about that
all week do you remember a Bill
Belichick pregame speech where you're
like wow
ha ha no no
the bill wasn't giving you and I I
remember being a senior in college and
uh Christiana was my coach at Rutgers
and Bill and him were close Steve uh was
a long sniper for us and eventually went
on the coaching and we're one in five I
think at the time and Bill comes in to
speak to the team his main message to us
was in a very monotone you guys want to
improve play better that's the key you
just need to play better we walked away
we won seven straight games after he
talked to us and we played better well
that was his message just played better
thanks appreciate it coach and he has no
emotion in his voice
no zero and the one good thing though it
stays the same no matter when loss or
whatever he'll be in meetings and he'll
be getting after somebody he'll be the
same boy I mean this is the effort we're
giving I mean my grandmother could get
down to feel faster than you can on this
so it was almost like he'd be attacking
you or you feel like a terrible football
player but you'd also be laughing
because the voice in which he did it in
you kind of felt like it was endearing
so you'd be in the back of the meeting
room laughing but like damn bill just
killed my confidence going into the week
but Brady would yell
Brady work Brady will have some good
ones uh before the game and I think it
was because I was old when I got to New
England I was in my 10th year and Brady
was 10 years older than me so it was
like when you see like your dad or your
uncle they get fired up about something
they show their passion like that was
Brady before the game and you knew like
he meant Absolute business when he
showed up on Sunday so he was always fun
to be around because you would make fun
of Brady the same way you would any of
your teammates and he loved it so now I
tell people all the time that was the
coolest thing about him he was just one
of the guys great to talk to you Jace
congrats on your success thanks for
joining us
I appreciate it anytime thanks for
having me Jason mccording NFL Network
good morning football great show uh
played cornerback for 13 seasons and won
the Super Bowl